help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
all right here's the first story from
the new york post
fbi agents say director christopher wray
has got to go lost control of the agency
fbi director christopher reyes lost the
confidence of rank-and-file fbi agents
after a senior bureau official left
under a cloud of accusations that he
shielded hunter biden's laptop from a
criminal probe and some believe the top
g-man should step down a new report says
quote i'm hearing from fbi personnel
that they feel like the director has
lost control of the bureau
kurt
how you pronounce it sued zach
a lawyer representing fbi whistleblowers
told the washington times in a report
published tuesday they're saying how
does this guy survive he's leaving he's
got to leave the fbi agents are telling
me they have lost confidence in rey all
ray does is go in and say we need more
training and we're doing stuff about it
or we will not tolerate his comments
come in the wake of tim tebow is that he
pronounces some people are saying it was
to beau is that what it is
tebow that's what i thought
jim tebow
quarterback yeah the same guy it is
tim tebow's a very christian quarterback
who uh yeah oh really
i forgot about that guy
oh hey how about that timothy
well this guy yeah there you go t
is the top agent in charge of the fbi
field office in washington either
resigning or being forced out the door
made claims he blocked investigations
into the first son's laptop
so this is this is this is big i mean
i'm not entirely sure anything actually
will happen here but this is what i've
been talking about for some time that
the culture war issues exist in all
facets of this country and and the the
the federal institutions are not exempt
from people watching garbage mainstream
media and believing garbage fake news i
got i really like the no-nonsense uh
attitude of some of these fbi agents and
really like if any agency on earth is
going to have a no-nonsense mindset it's
the fbi or one of them and they're
saying they're calling out ray for
acting like when they're like what are
you going to do what do you do we're
going to look into it and make sure that
we get better so that we can hit like
this platitudes is what they're called
usually you'll see like kamal or someone
will do it and it just kind of
goes under the radar no one really knows
how to how to counter it or to rebuff it
or to criticize it but these guys aren't
taking it they know that that's a that's
a crap answer i don't know i kind of
feel like
a lot of these guys are crooked i think
it's obvious by what's going on with
trump it's obvious by what happened with
russiagate all of that was fake complete
hoax
now they're going after trump claiming
it classified documents and it's like yo
he was the president
like he determines if it's classified
this is crazy and there are people who
are just they don't know how to use
google or even read politifact who are
like whoa look at the picture of the top
secret that proves it
they believe it and there are people at
the fbi who who are counting on this and
they're crooked and i think what's
happening with christopher wray is
they're like hey our credibility's shot
right now so our ability to be corrupt
is hindered by this guy's bad job can we
pretend like we're having reform and get
rid of him and then keep going about
being corrupt they had a lot of
complaints too the employees who
you know said that rey should resign one
of the things they said was that there
had been fabrication of terrorism cases
to elevate performance statistics and i
think that's actually really quite an
important detail because the biden
administration has used domestic
terrorism
as a you know crisis that they believe
we're having you've had merrick garland
saying that domestic terrorism is the
biggest threat to the u.s and if the fbi
has been jacking up those stats just to
make themselves look better you have the
entire
federal government basing their
determinations on something that's uh
bogus a lot of people are pointing out
that the doj posted publicly photos of
top secret documents and it's like okay
if they're classified then they just
break the law good question interesting
yeah it's because it's all fake i mean
it's oh you made a good point about the
fbi
trumping up terrorism charges i.e this
gretchen whitmer case i think there were
10 fbi agents involved in the section
yeah there were like more fbi agents
involved than actual guys i think that
these
it's just so funny that there's a lot of
people in the agency that are like i
don't want my kid in getting thrust into
some stupid civil war that was brought
up by my ineptitude or my avoidance of
doing nothing as as some corruption was
going on because i wouldn't stand for my
boss trumping up terrorism charges no i
think that's a really bad situation
i mean it's just so clearly
uh a problem because we have merrick
garland going on tv saying that domestic
terrorism is the biggest threat facing
the country he said that a number of
times
and you had biden saying that same thing
and if the fbi is faking it
then what are they pouring all this
money into what is the department of
justice doing you know they're
they're going after regular americans
that the fbi is claiming are terrorists
perhaps you know what are we what are we
doing like these whitmer guys were
uh hanging out around a campfire getting
high talking about
random garbage that they wanted to do
like you do when you hang around a
campfire and you're getting high right
like you say whatever well and then the
fbi jumps in and it's like oh we can
encourage these guys to go nuts they
bring in some hot chick who smokes weed
with them and hotel rooms you know and
you know you're gonna do whatever the
hot chick who's smoking weed with you
says that is the rule i would do that
what you mean
you're going to entertain it right
literally do it you're going to go in
the house then they had to like buy guns
for them and everything yeah yeah like
don't you want to go and do this like
sure whatever you say take your clothes
off and they're like we got him we got
him he said yes
that's why i'm you know i look at the
stuff and
i gotta wonder right these these guys
are gonna go to jail two guys there was
a mistrial then they had another trial
i'm seeing a lot of people report like
the judge wasn't allowing certain
testimony in and the whole thing they
say it was a sham the left is screaming
ah this proves it and i'm just like you
know i'm not entirely convinced there
will be a civil war
because we're watching for six seven
years now some of the most intense and
absolute corruption we've ever seen and
everyone's kind of just like huh
how about that kind of interesting but
but you know more importantly in 2018
democrats win
in 2020 they still held the house
despite victories from the right and
it's like
dude when they raid the former
president's house i hope i think it was
james lindsay you mentioned this that
some woman was like that's gone too far
for me like raiding a president's house
i hope that is true and come november
people are like but then not only do you
have to hope you'll win you have to hope
that the people who actually get in do
something right and that's a that's a
that's questionable as well because the
establishment gop and the establishment
democrats are basically the same thing
you know they're
right they're trying to maintain their
power the the mar-a-lago raid though is
crazy like you guys i'm sure looked at
the affidavit the
heavily redacted affidavit
uh
from what i could gather
the doj is mad that trump had documents
that he could have declassified he did
stored him properly he did declassify
right and they were stored like but
their big complaint is that they were
stored improperly this is but but so
right am i right about that i don't know
trump turned over boxes yeah to the
national archive upon request they then
said wow look at this classified stuff
he might have more
so they asked an fbi agent saying hey we
think trump has more documents and so
they said okay we'll get a search
warrant for them right but the idea that
these are you know classified documents
when trump tweeted a long time ago
before before leaving the white house
that he was declassifying all of these
reports that's correct they're just it's
just very clear on that it's another
hoax man and the reason why you know i'm
saying maybe there won't be a civil war
is because the left keeps believing this
stuff the machine keeps on a churning
and even if the republicans get in
they just say you know well we can't we
can't push too hard we had a couple of
republicans in here who are like we
can't impeach joe biden you know despite
all of the evidence of the malfeasance
and business illicit dealings with his
son not even an investigation
so what i think is when i say no civil
war what i mean is revolution the left
is engaged in some kind of revolution
there uh you've got the all the crazy
race ideology gender ideology stuff
you've got the uh you will own nothing
world economic forum stuff
and
it seems like
that's the direction we're heading
since 9 11 the american people have gone
nuts and it's more than just the united
states but people have gone totally
twisted on each other they've been
looking at each other like that maybe
we're the threat well we made a huge
mistake in allowing the authorization of
the patriot act that was a huge issue
yeah and what's happening is and nobody
cared i remember being stunned at the
time that so few people cared it's crazy
it's it's insane and the world is
creating a new government there's a
world government being formed right now
if the americans refuse to stop fighting
and they keep arguing with each other
when they end up getting a seat at the
table one no one's going to take them
seriously when they're forming their new
government and it's going to get formed
without us
and two
they might not even have a they might
not even have a say in what happens they
can literally have their new government
right this is like cloud schwab they
want to make it
any part of some world government where
people are you know leaders are not
elected yeah in the way that we elect
them i actually you know brexit gives me
hope because britain was just like we're
actually just still going to be britain
y'all like yeah that's a form of world
government is decentralized autonomy
like we could bring american ideals and
constitutionalism to the globe if we're
unified
what we're offering they don't want well
yeah that's why we would have to fight
is that if you want free speech we have
to regulate your speech right they're
telling you that we are fighting for
freedom and then simultaneously it is
1984 that's correct yeah i mean they're
the ones with this massive top-down
approach telling us how we have to live
how we have to you know deal with our
cars how we have to deal with our kids
how we have to deal with our families
and our homes all of this they're
telling us what to do telling us that
you know it's from the bottom up and the
middle out right doesn't biden say that
constantly and it's not it's just a
complete lie they want to control us
from birth to death and to go along with
what they want and i think that we just
i mean it's at the point where you just
have to say no to anything the federal
government offers but you need to re you
need to propose something different if
you just say no you'll slowly get
steamrolled well we had something we had
something great right we had
constitutional democracy and we're not
going to have that anymore like it's a
fight i mean i don't like the term fight
necessarily but it's a constant struggle
to maintain economic it is democracy the
the right constantly saying no wait
don't while the left keeps expanding
what they're doing well look at what's
happening in california now right like
with the
uh they're going to phase out
gasoline-powered cars and now they're
telling you you can't charge your ev
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
if you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8pm and
we'll see you all there
you